les cats contribuables il ya eu des
problèmes avec revenu québec sont
nombreux mais surprise tout indique que
ça s'améliore c'est ce que dit en tout
cas la protectrice du citoyen du québec
l'une des rares choses positives de son
rapport annuel qui disons le démontre
que les compressions du gouvernement ont
fait mal aux services publics il faut
faire un changement de cap
on sait maintenant encore une fois
donner les moyens de nos ambitions bon
la protectrice du citoyen a constaté une
baisse du nombre de plaintes provenant
d'entreprises
après avoir dénoncé l'an passé les
méthodes de vérification de revenu
québec
il paraît que ça augure bien pour
l'ensemble des contribuables est revenu
québec a présenté en janvier un nouveau
plan d'action afin de mieux accompagner
les citoyens et prévoit maintenant une
charte des droits des contribuables à
quoi s'attendre un meilleur service à la
clientèle dit on est à une approche plus
respectueuse l'institution fiscale
l'admet elle s'assure d'être plus
prudente et s'assure d'avoir respecté
les droits des particuliers
avant de passer à l'attaqué et entend
même avoir moins recours à la justice et
le saviez vous vous pouvez même poser
vos questions directement au revenu
québec sur sa page facebook
et on vous répondra en moins de 20
minutes on a fait le test
pour en savoir plus avec plus de détails
les i nous ici pour les radios tirer
canada.ca la section politique